-Guys, like I mentioned before,
President Trump was nominated
for a Nobel Peace Prize today,
and he's so confident
he's gonna win,
he already has his acceptance
speech written out.
In fact, earlier today,
he was practicing
in front of the mirror,
and we got the footage.
Check it out.
-Ladies and gentlemen of the
Nobel committee, what an honor.
I love Barnes & Nobel.
Great toy section.
Not sure about Barnes,
but I love Nobel.
I don't know Barnes.
Met him once.
But we're not here
to talk about Barnes, are we?
We're here to talk about me, the
winner of the Nobel Peace Prize.
It's great to be here in
beautiful, fantastic Norway.
We love Norway.
Don't we?
Love the "fuh-jords."
But you know who never
visited Norway, by the way?
Hillary.
Throwback to that.
I'm playing
all the hits tonight, folks.
All the hits.
Buckle up.
I got to be honest, this award
came at the perfect time.
For a second there,
I almost thought
I was doing a bad job
as president.
Can you believe that?
But you're right --
I'm amazing.
And I deserve this award
for many reasons.
For one, I finally brought peace
between the Arabs and Jews.
We love the Jewish people, or as
I call them the Yo-semites.
And now they're
getting along great
with the United Arab "Erimates."
Emirates?
United Arab Erima--
Until this morning, I thought it
was a European soccer team.
We're currently
looking into that.
Are we looking into it?
But what about education, folks?
Under my administration,
there have been so many books
written about me...
committing treason.
Michael Cohen wrote one,
John Bolton,
one of my hotter nieces.
So many...jobs created.
So many Showtime movies adapted.
And then, of course,
my biggest triumph.
Of course,
I'm talking about vitamin C.
The nana.
The Big Ronie,
as many people refer to it,
coronavirus.
And now folks are mad because
Bob Woodward --
Bob Woodward
has me on tape saying
I knew it would be deadly
back in February.
But to those folks,
I say, called it.
Remember that.
Big victory.
Big victory, folks.
But this celebration
is bittersweet, folks.
Let me just be clear --
[ Inhales sharply ] --
and let me just
clear my nose for a second.
[ Exhales sharply ]
It's a sad day for America.
I'm sure you've heard "Keeping
Up with the Kardashians"
is ending its run
as one of the greatest shows
in the history of broadcasting.
No more Kim, no more Kris,
no more Khloe
with her sassy remarks.
I wish them all well and invite
each and every one of them
to join my cabinet.
Finally, to all the little boys
and girls out there
who want to be president,
but let's be honest,
some people say it should only
be boys -- I don't know.
Some people say.
Some people say that.
To all the little boys,
let this be a reminder
that you can cyberbully your way
to a Nobel Peace Prize.
Just remember, be best.
And if that's not working,
be a little less best.
So, in conclusion,
peace in the Mideast,
"Keeping Up" is deceased,
and as always,
no ramps for my feets.
Invisible mic drop.